Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
in the book of fasting
in the chapter regarding
what is preferred, what is encouraged
and also what are the etiquets It's for
a person who is fasting.
Yesterday morning we began with an
important point and that is a and that
is that a person have a pre-dawn prefast
breakfast
and our prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam
tells us that the minimum of a is even
just one drink of water even just one
gulp of water.
Now with respect to when is the
appropriate time
to have a
when is the best time to have a
we have
who is narrating tob.
So these are two companions,
one more senior than the other,
narrating his experience with the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
He says,
[Silence]
said, "We had
which is pre-dawn breakfast." It's not
just breakfast, but it is breakfast just
before dawn with the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam
and then he got up and made salah. So
already this wording articulates that
there was very little time between the
act of eating and the salah because he
says we had with the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and then he got up and prayed.
So this wording here articulates that
there was not a lot of time and a lot
of delay between
the
and the salah. But he gets more specific
then asks
he says
and so
asks he says how long was the time
between
and the aen
and
answered saying around 50 verses
length recitation. So we mentioned that
this is roughly 10 to 12 minutes the the
time between the two. This narration is
collected by both bkari and Muslim
and
as a matter of fact it is the sunnah of
the prophet sallall.aii
that a person delay a
right up until right up until the adan
of fud. So much so that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam advises us
with respect to if we hear the aden
or if the time for adan comes in we have
our very precise
super fancy 2026
clocks and watches we are very
sophisticated people so if that moment
of adan comes in what do we do? Do we
immediately stop eating? Do we spit out
what's already in our mouths? Do we have
to stop a few minutes before?
What is the recourse?
[Silence]
was
The author says, "And if a person were
to hear the aden
whilst he has in his hand food or drink
and
the aden is heard, then it is
permissible for him to eat or drink what
is already in front of him. The author
says what is already in his hand.
However,
this narration is not just what is
in your hand as opposed to what's right
in front of you.
There is no difference between what is
in your hand coincidentally when the
adan comes in and what is on the table
in front of you. Rather the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam says as Abu narrates,
"If any of you hears the aden
and his cup is in his hand, then he is
not to put it down until he finishes
what
is in front of him."
meaning that a person finish what he has
his heart set on what he needs of that
drink or of that food. So there is
a minute or two where the adan may
happen to be cold. This is not for a
person to plan
to eat until the adan is called. Notice
the wording of the narration.
[Silence]
So the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam here instructs us we're not to
understand from the narration that a
person is to plan to eat or drink past
the exact moment that the adan is made.
Rather
what we understand from the narration is
there is a level of surprise there or
there is a there is an element of
coincidence there. the person is eating
or drinking and the time where the adan
is then called. The person may finish
what is in his hands, what is before him
quickly to you know one last drink of
water or you know whatever it is. This
is what our prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us and we also surmise
from this that the sunnah is for the to
be late as late as possible. As a matter
of fact in some narrations the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam explicitly
commands as much and he he he tells us
to delay
as much as possible and to and to hasten
breaking our fast at time.
The second thing the author mentions is
The next etiquette of fasting is that a
person refrain from.
So these two things
was
[Silence]
in Arabic.
Our prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
here prohibits us from what is okay.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala describes the
believers year round as
he describes the believers
as those who when they hear al they
ignore it. They turn away from it.
They do not engage in it. They do not
indulge it. They do not suffer. What is
alu?
Alu in the Arabic language
is literally the description of the
sounds that birds make.
The exact translation of
is Twitter. I'm not not making that up.
Sometimes in
Right? I mean that's actually the word
right in the dictionary that you would
look it up. Right? What is the sound
that birds make? The chirping. This is
called Twitter. All right.
So
in the Arabic language
is the sound the twitter that birds
make.
And the Arabs refer to something that is
useless, that is just a pastime,
something that has no benefit in it,
something that is inconsequential,
something that is immaterial. They refer
to it as it's nothing but a backdrop.
It's background noise, right? It's
background noise. Just the birds
chirping, we don't pay attention. We're
not missing much of if we were to
understand what they were saying, right?
If they're saying anything at all. And
so this is
in Islamic legislation in the language
of the Quran, language of the Sunnah. Al
is quantified
as any action or speech that has no
benefit. benefit meaning worldly benefit
somebody's livelihood or
benefit. There's no benefit to it. It's
what we refer to in the modern age as
killing time. Right? This is alu.
The next thing he mentions is
although
[Silence]
what is
a
in general
is any sinful
or
it is it is a general term used to refer
to that which is sinful
and especially that which is vulgar
of sinfulness.
And so
is vulgarity in general or it it is
sinfulness in general and vulgarity
specifically.
This is referred to as
now the prophet sallall.aii
specifically
tells us that we are to avoid
and
during our fast. If we were to look at
these two together in this context, what
it means is we are to avoid that which
is vulgar or sinful and that which has
no benefit.
Right? A person is doing something
they're the thing they are doing has to
be of consequence.
The thing they are speaking about is to
Killing time
is something that people are very
prone to while they're fasting.
Especially if a person has some kind
of vice or some kind of addiction. Now
they are trying to just
get through every second, do anything
just to get through the finish line so
that we can flood the body again with
whatever it is that it is craving. And
so part of the discipline of fasting
which is difficult I mean we all go
through this. We all have this
difficulty and it's part of our growing
process. It's not that a person is
either fasting or they're not. They're
either good or they're bad. No.
Even if a person were to spend the
entire day in
but there is half an hour left of their
fast and they come to their senses a
half an hour before they don't throw
that half hour away. They hold on to
that half hour. Look at Ramadan in
general. Not just the day of Ramadan,
but the month of Ramadan,
right? Every one of us had things that
we
wanted to see of ourselves during this
month. Whether it's something we wanted
to change about ourselves or something
that we wanted some new habit we wanted
to adopt, some new, some new worship.
And much of that,
some of that if not much of that
maybe didn't come to pass.
And the idea is that once we start to
stumble in the first week or 10 days,
Shan comes and tries to convince you to
to throw the whole rest of it away
because I mean, what's the point? But
you can turn this around. If you can
turn this ship around, even in the last
half hour of the last day of Ramadan,
right? If there is a half an hour left
of the last day, you throw away 29 and a
half days and there's one half left,
there's still one half left.
That one half could be that one thing
that tips your scales. that one
statement, that one dua with the heart
in the right place at the right moment,
that is the cause of being forgiven.
And so
there is a principle and that is
right.
[Silence]
and that is that
even if we haven't you know achieved the
whole thing we don't throw away all of
it just because of that right you hold
on to that last minutes of that last
hour of that last day. You can turn it
around right now. Let's say somebody,
you know, was not benefiting from
Ramadan at all in a total days
throughout the entirety of Ramadan and
just right now they're thinking about
themselves and they feel a bit of
remorse. They feel a bit of shame. They
feel repentance. They feel right now
this is the chance. This is a new day,
right? And this is not something that's
only in Ramadan, but obviously Ramadan
is an opportune time.
The point is is that these two things
are what we are to specifically go out
of our way to avoid. We are trying to
build a habit. How long does it usually
take for habits to take root?
Huh?
30 days. You said how much? 30. 30
roughly. It was 3 weeks a month. Is
that what psychologists tell us? Yes.
Okay. Well, as long as they say it, then
it must be true. So, it takes 30 days
roughly to break a habit, to build a new
habit. You know what that means? You
know what that means? If you were here
for every single day, every single night
throughout the month of Ramadan, that
has now become a habit. You are going to
have to go out of your way to break that
habit after Ramadan is over to not come.
If you spent the entire month of Ramadan
avoiding a particular thing, you have
now built a habit or broken a habit. and
to go back to that thing, you are now
going out of your way to rembbrace that
habit. That's what that means.
If you
came to the masid or if you made or
every night throughout the month of
Ramadan, first of all, congratulations
to you. But second of all, even if it is
two, you have now built a habit and
you've proven that you can do it and
that there is time and that you can make
time and that your very busy schedule
can fit it. You've just proven that. So
after Ramadan is over
to go ahead and
go back to that or to drop that habit,
you are literally
tearing down a habit that you've built
and
you know basically taking deliberate
steps backwards,
right? The habit's already there.
Imagine if just I know this is kind of
out there but just think about it.
Imagine if we kept the same amount that
we make in salah at night after is let's
say you made four every night of the of
the if you were to keep that retain that
until next year
and then next year you build something
else on top of that 10 15 20 years of
Ramadan's go by what kind of person
would you be after that that that time
unrecognizable and that's the whole
point of Ramadan but we don't advance
because every time Shael comes in we
take those steps back
because we can't imagine that there is
there are levels higher than that but
there are so many levels higher than
that and so much more
and so if a person were to retain ain
that one good habit or leave off that
one bad habit for that month of Ramadan.
Next year when Ramadan comes, you'll
have something else to build on top of
that. And once you start that inertia,
that that momentum going, it's very hard
to stop because the human being is prone
to what is called sunk cost. When you
invest in something, you are very
reluctant to abandon that thing after
having invested in it.
He says,
Abu
[Silence]
narrates that the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii Wasam
said, "If you are fasting any day, then
you are not to engage in vulgarity. You
are not to engage in obnoxious or loud
behavior or unruliness. And you are not
to engage in ignorance. And if anyone
were to insult you or attempt to argue
or fight with you, you are to say, "I
am fasting." You are to proclaim I am
fasting. And Abu likewise narrates that
the messenger of Allah
said whoever does not leave off false
speech and its implementation. So
anything haram but especially lying
then Allah has no use for him to leave
off his food and his drink. Imagine
this here.
These are habits that a person builds up
throughout the month. If you are to
retain these habits, just even let's
look at this
sitting in this little talk after
fudgel.
Those who are not used to sitting and
listening for 20 minutes to this kind of
information every day.
Can you not feel that once you forced
yourself to do it the first day and the
second day and the third that it became
easier? That over time it not only
became easier but it actually became
something you look forward to. that it
actually became something that you
wished wouldn't end that it would that's
exactly what the battle is between good
and evil for your heart. Right? And the
same thing goes for building habits. You
can't just imagine yourself to start a
good habit immediately. It takes time.
It's a muscle. You have to build it
over time. And the more you build it,
the stronger you become. I've
apparently bored some of us to to to
to sleep. So we will end with that
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
It's a little bit